au terme d'une semaine particulièrement
chargée je vous le disais dans les
titres et qui a vu tour à tour edouard
balladur puis jacques chirac présenté
leur programme présidentiel une série de
sondages qui enregistrait le bon début
de campagne de lionel jospin un
effritement de la cote de popularité qui
ne profite pas à d'edouard balladur qui
ne profitent pas jacques chirac le
premier ministre est ce soir notre
invité bonsoir vous allez répondre à nos
questions en compagnie d'arlette chabot
et d'alain duhamel je voudrais pour
commencer à évoquer une affaire qui
continue de défrayer la chronique la
sphère maréchal schuller votre service
de presse a confirmé que l'hôtel
matignon avait autorisé l'interception
de la ligne téléphonique du docteur
maréchal pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
jugé nécessaire ces écoutes
téléphoniques d'abord c'est la première
fois que le premier ministre ait un
communiqué de ce genre ne veut bien le
faire remarquer un souci de transparence
en second lieu les procédures sont
parfaitement claires quand il ya urgence
et urgence demandée par la police
judiciaire
dans un cas de flagrant délit et là il
s'agissait d'une affaire d'extorsion de
fonds et donc urgence
la procédure est accélérée mais ensuite
la commission de contrôle des
interceptions de sécurité doit donner
son aval elle a été prévenue et donc ça
s'est passé ainsi et au bout de six
jours l'interception a été arrêté tout a
été parfaitement régulier est
parfaitement légal et je répète que
c'est la première fois qu'un premier
ministre fait le communiqué que j'ai
fait samedi pour bien expliquer comment
les choses se sont passées alors c'est
bien qu'on est en campagne électorale à
que l'on sait qu'on est en campagne
électorale et que donc toutes les armes
sont bonnes mais je me permets de
rappeler que les problèmes de justice
ont été gérés par mon gouvernement avec
un scrupule un souci de transparence
totale et que personne ne peut me
reprocher ni reproché au garde des
sceaux pierre méhaignerie d'avoir fait
quoi que ce soit pour entraver le cours
de la justice et dans cette affaire je
répète que les procédures légales ont
été scrutés respectez le premier
ministre les écoutes téléphoniques
normalement son sont prévues compris
dans les cas d'urgence quand il s'agit
d'affaires d'une extrême importance le
terrorisme ou le grand banditisme ou
bien la sécurité de la france
apparemment ce produit tout une affaire
de cette importance alors qui a commis
une faute
d'évaluation non mais c'est luzarches
d'usagé parce que c'est quand même pas
ni saison d'interception existe depuis
des dizaines et des dizaines d'années il
ya eu une loi de 91 qui arrive j'ai
zappé légion 10 juillet qu'un usage est
de l'admettre dans ces cas là dans les
cas de tentative d'extorsion de fonds et
de et de chantage
l'hôtel matignon les collaborateurs du
premier ministre ont uniquement à
vérifier la régularité de la procédure
ils n'ont pas à refaire l'instruction
des choses faute de quoi il y aurait
plus urgence quand on vous téléphone
notamment des affaires de trafic de
drogue on dira je demande que très
rapidement
on interviennent parce qu'il ya un
flagrant délit on va pas recommencer
toute l'instruction de choses rappelle
que les choses se sont passées de façon
parfaitement régulière parfaitement
régulière je mets au défi quiconque de
prouver le contraire de prouver le
contraire en tout cas je veux dire
quelque chose parce que depuis quelques
semaines ya effectivement toute une
série d'affaires qui sont présentés de
façon très
pathétique ou émotive je vois très bien
pourquoi faisant campagne électorale dis
pas ça pour vous je m'empresse de vous
le dire
cela ne fait que renforcer ma
détermination de renforcer ma
détermination
je suis responsable de la gestion de
notre pays dans une période difficile
qui est une période de cohabitation
j'ai pris l'engagement de gérer notre
pays et de le diriger dans les
meilleures conditions possibles jusqu'à
la fin j'assumerai ma responsabilité
vous aviez rappeler à l'ordre
monsieur toubon votre ministre pour
manquement à la solidarité
gouvernementale parce que vous avez
demandé de vous expliquer sur cette
affaire ne regrettez-vous pas en même
temps que le ministre de l'intérieur
dans une réunion publique et dénoncer
certaines dérives des juges est donc mis
en accusation n'ait jusqu'ici pas les
progrès tarn madame je disais tout à
l'heure que je rende un hommage à pierre
méhaignerie pour la façon dont il a géré
et affirmées rappelons bousquet ta
situation il ya deux ans tout de même en
france tout le monde a oublié ce
qu'était la situation de la france et 2
ans l'indépendance et la transparence
des procédures de la justice de la même
manière je tiens à rendre hommage à
charles pasqua qui est un excellent
ministre de l'intérieur grâce auquel
l'insécurité à reculer la lutte contre
le terrorisme connu des succès et en
plus l'aménagement du territoire qui est
une grande idée est en train d'entrer en
en pratique bien
cela étant les problèmes du rapport de
la justice de la société de la politique
sont des problèmes qui à notre époque
deviennent extrêmement tendue c'est
pourquoi nous avons fait une série de
réformes pour notamment accroître
l'indépendance des juges et nous l'avons
cru pu le zm en respecter mais dans le
cadre de leur obligation
fonctionnel
le ministre de l'intérieur et le
ministre de la justice n'ont pas
nécessairement la même orientation je
dirais que c'est dans une certaine
mesure normale mais justement il se
trouve que pour offert l'arbitrage ya un
premier ministre et qu'il le fait pour
en terminer avec ce premier sujet en
deux mots le juge jean pierre qui est
qui est maintenant député européen sur
la liste de philippe de villiers a dit
aujourd'hui que en somme votre
gouvernement vous même vous faisiez
aussi mal que les socialistes en ce qui
concerne les affaires d'écoutés
téléphoniques
eh bien écoutez je le mets au défi de le
prouver je le mets au défi de le prouver
moi j'ai ma conscience pour moi dans
cette affaire et je n'accepterai pas
d'être mise en cause je le répète dans
n'importe quelles conditions
alors si quelqu'un peut prouver que mon
gouvernement n'a pas respecté
scrupuleusement les règles de la
déontologie et de la morale et du
respect des droits des personnes en la
matière qu'ils viennent ici invité le
demandez lui des explications est qu'ils
apportent ses preuves et a souvent
l'avouerez à vitré si le csa le veut
bien et je répondrai ses premiers
ministres une toute une série de
sondages ont été publiés cette semaine
il marque une érosion de votre cote de
popularité
on savait qu'après la déclaration de
votre candidature les sondages allée b c
est ce que vous avez été surpris par
l'importance de cette baisse
importance inégale selon les instituts
tout de même jouer simplement faire une
observation quand les sondages étaient
très basses qui a été quand même assez
fréquent on disait les sondages ça
pollue la démocratie faut pas en parler
il commence à être moins bon pour toute
une série de raisons d'ailleurs la
sphère des iut j'espère que nous en
parlerons et on va en irak l'alchimie
l'air j'espère aussi l'ouverture de la
campagne et on dira oui j'ai qu'une
chose à vous répondre monsieur
les choses étant ce qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui
et si elle le reste je crois que tous
les autres échangerait bien leur champ
de leurs sondages avec les miens mais
votre avis c'est le jeu normal de la
compagnie il ya une sorte de désamour
j'allais dire à l'égard des noirs de
lier votre avis que c'est un mouvement
de fond c'est normal
je ne sais pas je pas posé la question
en termes de sentiment je crois que
c'est le jeu normal de la campagne je
n'ai jamais cru à à des résultats
hyperbolique la france et la france avec
ses traditions avec les convictions de
chacun ses attitudes ses attachements
sentimentaux et la politique c'est bien
souvent bien plus qu'une affaire de
sentiments que de raison ou de logique
et la france étant la france lorsque
l'on lisait dans les sondages ya
quelques mois au second tour le candidat
de la majorité ferait 60 65 % des voix
contre un candidat qui serait celui de
l'opposition je n'y ai pour ma part
jamais cru les choses se reclasse et se
reclasse tout à fait normal il ya un
autre point qui a été soulevée
évidemment ces derniers jours qui est la
sphère des iut et à propos des iut et du
fait qu'il ya eu une circulaire et puis
que finalement gouvernement l'a retirée
on a posé la question de ce qu'on
appelle la méthode balladur alors est ce
que la méthode balladur c'est le repli
élastique pas du tout c'est le respect
du citoyen et d'ailleurs si je cherchais
une démonstration du bien-fondé de cette
méthode je la trouverai dans ce que vous
venez de dire quoi s'agit-il
le gouvernement une politique nous
sommes en république c'est le
gouvernement qui doit fixer la politique
deux universités de les connaissez pas
c'est pas l'administration la politique
parfaitement clairs tels que je n'ai
arrêté en accord avec françois fillon le
ministre de l'université
il n'y a pas deux catégories de jeunes
ceux qui sont faits pour les études
courtes qui n'ont droit qu'aux études
courtes qui une fois qu'ils ont terminé
leurs études courtes doivent se trouvait
bien contents qu'on leur offre un emploi
et puis les autres les privilégiés qui
aurait lieu de droit des études longues
et qu'il poursuivrait tandis que leurs
camarades des iut n'aurait pas le droit
d études donc c'est totalement contraire
à ma conception des choses la justice de
l'équité de la liberté je constate au
contraire que beaucoup d'aces de jeunes
suivent les cours des iut pour avoir un
diplôme qui leur permettent d'assurer
leur avenir professionnel mais en même
temps ensuite ils veulent pouvoir aller
dans une autre direction
il ne faut pas les en empêcher une
circulaire administrative a fait naître
le doute et bien cette circulaire devait
être revue et j'ai décidé qu'elles le
seraient et elle l'est c'est
parfaitement clair c'est le gouvernement
qui fixe à politique et si je voulais
chercher une démonstration du bien-fondé
de ma façon de faire la trouverez là si
une simple circulaire
mais en pareilles et moi des milliers
des dizaines de milliers de jeunes est
ce que ça ne prouve pas qu'il faut
discuter et dialoguer pour essayer de
comprendre avant de décider le monde a
changé alain duhamel vous le savez aussi
bien que moi nous ne parlons pas à nos
enfants comme nos parents nous parlait
est ce que vous croyez que dans les
entreprises aujourd'hui y compris à
france 2 on commande comme ont commandé
il ya vingt ans de façon péremptoire et
autoritaire tout ça c'est terminé france
2 sûrement pas comme ça c'est terminé
c'est la démocratie moderne c'est le
dialogue et c'est le contrat et je n'ai
pas du tout l'intention de changer de
méthode et vous dire même plus une des
raisons pour lesquelles j'ai décidé de
présenter ma candidature
c'est que d'abord je suis persuadé que
la france a besoin outre toutes celles
que nous avons faites et qui sont
considérables de grandes réformes
peut-être en parlerons nous mais qu'elle
a également besoin de paix sociale et
que ma méthode est la même ailleurs pour
avoir la paix sociale et c'est justement
l'une des justifications à mes yeux de
ma candidature à ceux qui vous disent
que vous ne savez que reculer que vous
faites de petits pas en avant deux pas
en arrière quand vous manqué de courage
pour certains ont fait de grands pas en
arrière il ya quelques années après des
drames
valéry giscard d'estaing dans un
article qui vous a consacré vendredi
dans libération que t'es pas
particulièrement charitable vous a
reproché dans l'expression et la
présentation de votre projet de manquer
du sens des ce qu'il appelle les actes
forts au fond vous ne seriez c'est
quelque chose qu'on entend au fond vous
le seriez quelqu'un de pas assez
franchement réformiste ne prenant pas
assez de risques qu'est-ce que vous
incite à dire d'abord je constate
quelque chose c'est que dans cette
campagne qui s'ouvre où il ya déjà
presque une dizaine de candidats ils ont
tous un point commun tous sauf moi c'est
de s'en prendre à moi on dirait que
c'est normal dessus premier ministre
donc tout ce qui ne va pas bien dans
notre pays mais imputer ce qui est
légitime d'une certaine manière
premier point deuxième point nous avons
fait je le répète des réformes très
importantes qu'on attendait depuis des
années la réforme du code de la
nationalité la réforme des retraites ou
celle de l'aménagement du territoire ou
celle de la justice
il y à des réformes très importantes
qu'il faut faire à l'avenir je pas en
faire l'énumération devant vous et la
réforme de l'assurance maladie ussel le
du premier cycle de l'enseignement
supérieur ou la location dépendance
voilà des réformes importantes bien
alors que propose-t-on d'autres
j'écoute que propose-t-on
j'entends certains dire
il faudrait augmenter tous les salaires
beaucoup bien c'est ce qu'ont direct ça
l'ined est et on gagne on est sur des
effets que cela aurait sur l'emploi
j'ai été le premier à dire que les
salaires directs étaient d'un montant
trop faible dans notre pays et qu'il
fallait alléger les allocations fallait
les cotisations des entreprises pour
permettre l'augmentation des salaires il
se trouve que nous sommes dans une
situation d'emploi qui est maintenant je
l'espère stabilise et après la décrue du
chômage qui fait qu' on ne peut pas dire
comme ça de façon autoritaire il faut
augmenter les salaires bien d'autres
disent il faut une baisse brutale des
cotisations de 60 80 milliards pour
permettre aux entreprises d'avoir moins
de charges ils disent il faut alléger
les charges plus que vous même ne
suggérait que je ne le fais mais alors
je pose la question où trouve-t-on les
80 milliards pour supprimer charge des
entreprises est ce qu'on va augmenter le
déficit du budget de l'état ou est-ce
qu'on veut créer 3 4 points de tva ou un
point et demi de csg est ce que c'est ça
qu'il faut faire en ce moment ma réponse
est non ma réponse est non et d'autres
disent ah mais il faut laisser croître
normalement naturellement les dépenses
d'assurance maladie dans tous les pays
au monde quand vous dites d'autres là en
l'occurrence c'est jacques chirac qui
dit que la priorité n'est pas de
contenir les dépenses mais de veiller à
ce que l'évolution économique permettent
de revenir à l'équilibré naturel avec
moins de chômeurs dans dans la situation
de la france d'aujourd'hui avec 275
milliards de déficit budgétaire auront
réduit de 65 milliards milan reste le
175 avec 50 milliards de déficit des
comptes sociaux c'était 110 reste encore
50 la priorité c'est de réduire les
déficits
faute de quoi nous ne réglerons jamais
le problème du chômage voilà ma
conviction profonde et pour réduire les
déficits il nous l'avons fait dans toute
une série de secteurs je vous rappelle
l'assurance chômage ce qu'on y est
convenu d'appeler la médecine
ambulatoire c'est dur la médecine de
ville les retraites il faut une action
constante de conviction et de dialogue
là aussi
il faut réduire les déficits tout en
disant effectivement par ailleurs que la
fiscalité ne doit pas volonté c'est
possible à l'écouter il faut faire les
deux choses à la fois c'est d'ailleurs
ce que nous avons fait nous avons réduit
la fiscalité notamment sur l'impôt sur
le revenu et en même temps nous avons
réduit les déficits mais tout est une
question de mesure moi ce que je
constate
n'est ce pas on nous avait dit que la
campagne électorale serait l'occasion
d'un débat de société
un débat de société
j'ai pas encore aperçu la description
d'une société fondamentalement
différente de celle que je propose dans
laquelle qui est davantage d'égalité des
chances
davantage de liberté pour les citoyens
aient une plus grande influence la
france dans le monde ce sont les trois
axes des propositions en revanche il
peut y avoir des désaccords bien entendu
sur les façons d'y parvenir et c'est
parfaitement légitime et j'aimerais que
nous puissions en parler moi j'ai fait
toute une série de propositions par
exemple l'allocation parentale
d'éducation dès le premier enfant est
une chose forte importante pour la
liberté de chacun par exemple de donner
à chacun le droit de faire trois années
de formation supplémentaires au cours de
la vie pour avoir une seconde chance
pour pouvoir se reclasser mieux autre
exemple par exemple la prime pour
l'achat d'un premier appartement par les
ménages une prime qui remplacerait
toutes les aides existantes on peut
débattre de tout ça on peut dire que
c'est bien que c'est pas bien que c'est
assez que c'est trop mais je ne vois pas
dans tout ça la description d'une autre
société nous devons avoir une autre
société dans laquelle je le répète est
plus d'égalité plus de liberté mais je
ne vois pas de désaccord jusqu'à présent
entre les différents candidats sur ce
point c'est plutôt une question de
mesure à prendre quand vous dites les
différents candidats vous pensez à
jacques chirac ou bien vous et où
philippe de villiers ou bien vous pensez
aussi à lionel jospin il n'a pas encore
dit grand-chose lundi peut parler quand
même il a un peu plus d'un an il a un
peu parlé mais il n'a pas encore dit
grand chose nous verrons bien s'il
entend prendre la suite des 14 années
deux septennats socialiste que nous
venons de vivre ou s'il entend prendre
une autre direction lorsque je le
saurais je vous répondrai à plusieurs
reprises j'ai fini au fond il mesure
nous avons déjà commencé alors vous un
peu reproché en présentation justement
de votre programme vient de manifester
je veux dire une certaine continuité on
dit c'est la continuité on arrive à ce
programme ces programmes d'un premier
ministre qui veut continuer à matignon
et ça manque de souffle présidentielle
alors vraiment qu'elle souffre
présidentielle alors
bas je suis mal placé pour vous répondre
mais je vous répondre sur les autres
points
d'abord le bilan de ce gouvernement
cinquante même s'il était mauvais tout
le monde en parle mais personne
n'en parle pourquoi parce qu'il n'est
pas mauvais je dis pas qu'il est
excellent j'avais pris un engagement
quand je suis arrivé il y aura bientôt
deux ans laissez la france quand je
quitterai ma fonction pendant deux mois
deux mois et demi en meilleur état que
je ne les trouvait cet engagement est
tenu d'en c'est déjà aujourd'hui
dire
s'il était mauvais on en discuterait de
ce bilan je peux vous le promettre si on
en discute pas c'est qu'il est jugée
convenable convenable je ne dis pas bon
bien donc je laisserai le gouvernement
de la france en meilleur état que je ne
les trouvais ça c'est une chose sûre
bien à partir de là il faut aller plus
loin je voulais d'y faire une série de
réformes j'ai voulu proposer un certain
nombre de mesures importantes dans ma
conférence de presse à londres a dit ah
oui mais vous vous comportez comme un
premier ministre vous vous demandez
relais de chavaux qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un président de la république
qu'est ce que c'est c'est quelqu'un qui
se présente devant les français pour
leur dire faites pas confiance pour sept
ans et qui ne leur dirai pas où il va
les conduire qui ne leur dirai pas ce
qu'il compte faire avec le gouvernement
et la majorité pour que l'égalité des
chances soient mieux assurer qu'ils ne
leur dirai pas ce qu'ils comptent faire
pour que la france soit plus influente
en europe ou dans le monde qui leur
dirai pas comment il va assurer
davantage de liberté aux français alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait dire votez pour
moi je ne ferais rien et je ne dirai
rien quand quand sur l'absurde absurde
sur sur ce thème précis justement
jacques chirac explique que selon lui il
ya deux conceptions de la présidence qui
a la sienne qui serait au fond un retour
à la pratique du général de gaulle où le
président inspirerait henry entre m et
ne gèreraient pas et puis à la vôtre dit
il qui serait celle d'une sorte de super
premier ministre vous voyez cette
différence vous la veillée partenaires
ont pas du tout savoir absolument pas
tout ça ce sont des mots d'ailleurs tous
les candidats présidentiels
propose des mesures sur le logement sur
les salaires sur l'assurance maladie
tout le monde fait la même chose et
c'est à juste titre l'élection
présidentielle c'est pas un chèque en
blanc qu'on demande en français voilà je
viens devant vous je vous parle je ne
vous dit rien de ce que je ferais faites
moi confiance et votez pour moi non ça
ne peut pas marcher comme ça et qu'ils
ont i dentielle c'est d'abord un projet
que les français approuvent ou
n'approuve pas et c'est ensuite un homme
ou une femme auxquels il faut confiance
ou auxquelles ils ne font pas confiance
et voilà il ya deux d'un mot il ya deux
points précis sur lesquels valéry
giscard d'estaing dans l'arctique dont
on parle et vous reprochez au fond de ne
pas être assez hardies et même d'être
plutôt en arrière par rapport à ce que
vous laissiez entendre avant et qui sont
le quinquennat présidentiel du il
m'avait écrit qu'il était pour
maintenant il est contre et les réformes
en ce qui concerne la réforme des
institutions européennes et vous
reproche au fond de ne pas vouloir leur
donner assez d'ampleur est-ce que sur
ces deux points vous avez une réponse à
lui donner je ne voudrais pas que notre
conversation de ce soir fut consacrée
exclusivement à répondre tout les
reproches ou toutes les critiques qui
peuvent mettre fait 102 points
importants dont on parle pas tellement
finalement bien je ris et kényanes pour
nous plaire je vais donc vous répondre
mais je serais levé très bien le bien
entendu je suis là pour ça mais je
souhaiterais de ne pas me définir
nécessairement par rapport à tous les
autres que comme je voulais dit il comme
lors de leur point commun à tous et s'en
prendre à moi si je passe mon temps à
répondre à tout le monde je n'aurais
jamais le temps de dire ce que je
souhaite ce que je pense et ce que je
veux pour notre pays alors je vais vous
répondre quand même premier point la
durée du mandat présidentiel
j'ai longtemps c'est vrai était pour le
quinquennat renouvelable
mais y ayant réfléchi je me rends compte
que ça risque de présenter un danger de
modification de nos institutions et
qu'il vaut mieux je pense que le
président est un mandat plus lent
d'autre part je crois que 14 ans c'est
beaucoup trop long
et dans ces conditions j'en suis venu à
l'idée mais je dis mon inclination j'ai
pas dis ma décision que c'était
peut-être le septennat non renouvelable
qui était la meilleure formule mais j'ai
dit également que le problème serait
débattue au parlement il aura à débattre
pour dire ou bien on ne change rien ou
bien on fait le quinquennat ou bien on
fait deux septennats non renouvelables a
complètement ouvert bien vous indiquerez
une préférence j'indiquerai ma
préférence mais ce sera ouvert bien
entendu il appartiendra au parlement de
faire
c'est à dire que s'il y avait une
majorité qui se dégage et au parlement
pour le quinquennat vous accepteriez par
exemple de poser ensuite la question par
référendum absolument je la poserai ce
serait d'ailleurs différent de ce qui
s'est fait depuis vingt ans parce que
j'observe qu'un certain nombre de
partisans du quinquennat ont quand même
eu l'occasion depuis 20 ans de poser la
question au peuple depuis 20 ans que
c'est voter et ne l'ont pas fait alors
vous me posez une deuxième question sur
l'europe au four ils vous reprochent de
manquer d'ampleur dans l'idée de des
réformes institutionnelles mais écoutez
nous sommes en train de préparer la
conférence intergouvernementale de 96
des objectifs sont clairs l'europe
s'élargit il faut adapter ces
institutions comment faut que le conseil
des ministres est un rôle d'impulsion pu
nettement marqué il faut que les
procédures devant l'assemblée soit plus
simple elles sont incompréhensibles
aujourd'hui il faut que les parlements
nationaux soient mieux associer tout
cela the lady est tous là si les
français me font confiance je le ferai
je ne vois pas très bien ce qu'il faut
faire de différent
monsieur balladur au cours de la
présentation de son projet présidentiel
jacques chirac a été relativement sévère
tout de même avec le bilan de la france
il dit la machine est en panne toute la
semaine il ya eu des attaques croisées
entre balladuriens et chiraquiens
qu'est-ce que vous décidez de faire de
les ignorer mais qu'est ce que je fais
selon vous monsieur depuis une vingtaine
de minutes que je devant vous
il ne répondrait donc pas jacques chirac
c'est vrai que je versé ensemble la
réflexion et l'analyse de faux
différentes sur l'état de la france
aujourd'hui c'est vrai vous vous dites
la france effectivement va mieux et
certains disent en face la france va mal
qu'on lui rappelait etienne à l'instant
il ya une vraie fracture sociale est ce
que vous ressentez vous même cette vraie
structure sociale en france mais bien
entendu mais bien entendu nous avons
plus de 3 millions de chômeurs vous
n'attendez pas que je vous dise que je
mens satisfait que je trouve ça bien
nous avons arrêté la dégradation du
chômage pense maintenant pouvoir le dire
en 94 mais nous avons un immense semin
faire j'ai fixé un objectif
deux cent mille chômeurs de moins par an
pendant cinq ans au revoir un million de
chômeurs de moins au bout de cinq ans ce
pas une promesse que je fais c'est un
objectif que nous devrions deux fils et
pour être à peu près comparable aux
autres pays
d'autre part toutes les mesures que j'ai
proposé pour les chômeurs en fin de
droits pour la deuxième chance pour tous
pour la baisse des cotisations
d'assurance maladie pour baisser le coût
du travail tout cela va dans le sens la
diminution du chômage qu'on ne me fasse
pas dire à dire ce que je ne dis pas je
ne prétends pas que tout est réglé dans
notre pays ce serait absurde et
mensonger que de dire je dis simplement
quelque chose a été fait nul ne peut le
nier quand nous sommes arrivés il y
avait la récession économique
aujourd'hui à 3% de croissance quand
nous sommes arrivés il y avait trente
mille chômeurs de plus tous les mois
aujourd'hui nous avons faim 94
stabiliser le chômage et nous allons je
l'espère commencé à le réduire il ya
quand même des choses qui vont mieux la
sécurité va mieux qu'elle n'allait les
problèmes de l'agriculture française ont
été en large partie réglé parce que nous
avons gagné la négociations du gatt
alors vous savez c'est comme la sphère
du verre à moitié vide ou à moitié plein
moi je dis qu'il est à moitié plein bon
d'autres peuvent dire qu'il est à moitié
vide mais suffisamment c'est la même
discussion qui est écrit au second tour
vous vous attendez à ce qui est un
représentant de la majorité et lionel
jospin ou est-ce qu'à vos yeux il y a
une vraie chance ou un vrai risque j'en
sais rien qu'il y ait deux représentants
de la majorité je voudrais vous dire
quelque chose c'est que nous avons perdu
déjà deux élections présidentielles en
81 ans 88 nous avons perdu quoi qu'on
dise parce que nous étions 10
je souhaiterais donc que la campagne qui
commence depuis quelques semaines ne
prenne pas un tour trop venimeux et
inutilement venu parce qu'après tout
c'est parce que les français attendent
j'ai bien qu'ils aiment bien un peu le
spectacle de temps à autre et que une
campagne électorale présidentielle ya
une part de spectacle mais ce qu'ils
veulent c'est du sérieux c'est la
bruyère ils disaient les français
attendent du sérieux de ceux qui les
gouvernent il y avait bien raison est un
humoriste oui mais il avait raison quand
même
donc
nous avons perdu deux fois
j'aimerais bien qu'on ne perd pas une
troisième
et pour ne pas perdre une troisième il
faut que nous soyons le plus rassemblés
possible et que nous évitions nous
évitions toutes les humeurs inutile
toutes les méchancetés inutile et tous
les coûts inutiles
alors à partir de là
la france est la france avec sa
tradition avec ses équilibres faut pas
la gauche a été très sévèrement battue
comme jamais dans son histoire en 93
enfin il ya déjà deux ans et elle a
refait une partie de ses forces
donc la normale la normale ce serait
qu'il y ait un candidat de la majorité
face au candidat des socialistes
d'ailleurs comme le problème cette
sortie ou pas sortir des deux septennats
socialiste nul ne serait mieux placé
pour en débattre que celui qui se
présentera dans la continuité de ce
septennat
ce qui n'a joué le signale pas mon cas
car contrairement à ce que j'entends
parfois je ne suis pas le dernier
premier ministre socialiste de monsieur
mitterrand mais je suis le premier
ministre qui en 93 et pris la
responsabilité d'engager la france dans
une voie nouvelle et votre adversaire
c'est lionel justin où jacques chirac
dit renommée gers on vous dit vous me
posez pas être assemblées on vient ici
pour celles à nous poser des questions
je souhaite qu'on sorte des deux
septennats socialiste je souhaite qu'on
tourne la page à partir de là
celui qui est à mon avis se présente
comme étant le continuateur de ses deux
septennats socialiste est celui qu'il
faut affronter ce qui se profile simple
que ça ce qui signifie que si par
hypothèse par exemple y avait un second
tour entre lionel jospin jacques chirac
vous appelleriez à voter résolument
massivement et énergiquement sa faveur
mais bien entendu je suis sûr qu'il fera
la même chose dans une pose la question
on lui posera sûrement quand on recevra
ici et nous recevons de nombreux
candidats à l'élection présidentielle je
voudrais avoir votre réaction sur une
information philippe seguin a déclaré
tout à l'heure à 7 sur 7 en marge
précisément de la sphère maréchal
schuller par laquelle nous commencions
cette interview qu'il souhaitait s'il
n'y avait pas d'explication de la part
des responsables de l'état en
l'occurrence l'elysée pour les écoutes
83 86 et l'hôtel matignon pour la faire
maréchal schuller qu'il souhaitait
qu'une commission d' enquête sur ces
questions soient mises en place ces
explications je vous les ai données
on verra bien si elles sont jugées
suffisantes moi je vous ai dit tout ce
que je savais en tout cas je n'en sais
pas plus
balladur merci à les sabots merci alain
duhamel je vous précise que demain soir
c'est raymond barre qui sera l'invité de
la france en direct